hello there I'm Colonel of our host of
HBO's last week tonight oh we don't
actually have a show this week and we
taped this before we went away so I
don't know what awful things have
happened in the world since July first
Envy me I honestly don't know I'm
actually living in the past the thing
that you're thinking right now I don't
know yet and it's absolute heaven in any
case we just wanted to check in with you
to present the third installment of last
week tonight's lost graphics every week
our fantastic team of graphic designers
creates some truly ridiculous images
many of which we end up cutting but
which still deserve to be seen by you
the internet for instance there's this
image of a makeup artist applying Rouge
to the face of a salmon which was
presumably designed to illustrate a joke
but looks a lot more like porn for
people who are sexually attracted to
seafood we also created the created this
graphic depicting a box of condoms for
dogs are properly called Rough Riders I
don't honestly don't know why we made
this one but the important thing is on
this show dogs that's canon we also
never got to the chance to show you this
picture of a journalist squirrel his
name is obviously Edward our borough
because he digs deep whether he's
investigating a story or burying a
little nuts with his tiny small hands
now some graphics were a little more
unsettling like this image of a red
panda feasting on one of my internal
organs something that apparently I'm
delighted by or or this graphic of
Ivanka Trump as the mother from get out
and
it looks eerily real because it's
depressingly plausible we also designed
this pair of hockey playing badges which
people from Wisconsin will hate because
they're from Minnesota there's also this
woman in a hospital holding her newborn
watermelon and this disgruntled
parrot-like creature who seems to be
angry about something which
coincidentally was the working title of
this show now some some of our graphics
are weirdly specific like this image of
a Civil War soldier pecking a racist
unicorn next to Abraham Lincoln there's
no way to know what that means but I
think we can all agree with Abraham
Lincoln that it definitely deserves a
thumbs-up there's also this incredible
image of Nancy Reagan sitting on the lap
of mr. t who's dressed like Santa Claus
which to be honest wasn't cut from our
show because it was never part of our
show that's a real photograph I just
thought it was important to remind you
magic exists but that is all for now we
will be back as soon as we can but in
the meantime please enjoy this baffling
image of one of our staff members
banging a cheesecake in an industrial
kitchen it's pretty embarrassing for
that staff member but at least I didn't
refer to Jeremy by name the point is
we'll be back on HBO July 29 good night
you